-So lovely to have you here.
-So lovely to be here.
-So, this is very exciting.
You will be starting January 3rd
in Congress.
You, however,
also very impressive in 2016 --
Teacher of the Year --
and you met President Obama.
-Oh, yeah.
-And you...
-Oh, yeah. [ Laughs ]
-This is -- I'm glad --
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, I do want to --
We brought a clip.
And I -- two years later,
it seems like
you still are processing
that you met President Obama.
Let's just show everyone
how you reacted then.
-It is now my privilege...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
I'm sorry.
Don't kick me out.
[ Laughter ]
-No, you're doing good.
Jahana cares
about the example she sets
as much as the exams
that she scores.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What...
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you --
you just need to settle down.
-I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-So, you have to tell me...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Did...
When you left there in 2016,
did you already have
in your head
that you wanted to come back,
that you wanted
to run for office?
-I had in my head, "They're
never letting me back in here."
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-So what steps led
to you deciding to --
to make a run for this?
-Well, 2016
was a really tricky year.
-Mm-hmm. Yep.
-A lot happened.
And I'm
a high-school history teacher.
I had really been teaching kids
to get involved
in their communities,
to be a part of the solution.
And it felt like that narrative
was slipping away,
that people
weren't conducting themselves
in a way
that was solution driven, so...
-So now you're in D.C.
-Yeah.
-And it is freshman orientation.
-And there are a lot of freshmen
there this year,
a lot of new congresspeople
in D.C.
As a teacher, does it feel
like actual orientation
that you would have
for students?
-Absolutely not.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
First of all,
children conduct themselves
so much more responsibly
than adults.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
-Yes.
Young people are open
to just hearing about ideas
that are different from theirs,
learning about other people.
And, of course,
you have an adult in the room
who says, you know, these are
parameters by which we behave.
All bets are off in D.C.
-Yeah.
-It's a lot different.
Orientation was a lot different.
-I also -- you know, anyone --
when Republicans
come in to serve,
when Democrats come in to serve,
when you are
freshmen congresspeople,
a lot of people have run
on the idea
that Congress is dysfunctional.
This is, I would say,
the one thing that's nonpartisan
is everybody says what's
currently there is a mess.
Have you found it dysfunctional
already?
-Well, I mean, I don't want
to criticize anyone because,
of course, they have a system
by which they operate.
But, I mean, you go in --
everything is separated
by Republican and Democrat.
Even our first vote --
literally, it took us
about two hours to vote.
You picked up a paper
on one side of the room.
You checked a box.
You took it
to the other side of the room.
And I'm sitting there like, "You
know, there's an app for that."
Like...
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
We could have done this
in five minutes.
-Yeah.
-And I'm just watching it,
because you hear.
And I'm like
"Oh, my God, this is real."
-Yeah.
-So is it --
-It's a good thing we're here.
It's a good thing we're here.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean,
it just seems like so --
I mean -- So, there are just
so many inefficiencies, right?
Not even about politics.
-Right.
-Just people doing things
in a slow, stupid way.
[ Laughter ]
-What he said.
-I said it. I said it.
-Yes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, I think --
and a lot of it is just,
this is how
we've always done it.
-Mm-hmm.
-And in my mind, I'm thinking,
but is it a rule?
Can we change it?
-Yeah.
-Can we do it different?